Wir haben ja live vom staat der falken haben berichtet der aktuell größten rakete, der welt der absolute wahnsinn
Aber es geht noch größer, wenn es nach dem willen von elenas geht
Die big felken rocket oder auch big fucking rocket kurz
Bfh ist noch mal deutlich größer und wenn alles klappt soll sich schon in wenigen jahren, die ersten siedler zum mars bringe
Ich weiß, da gibt es eine menge fragezeichen, aber eines wurde jetzt beantwortet nämlich
Wo wie und warum, die bfa hergestellt wird herzlich willkommen zu den villen, mass chroniken bei klick zum science fiction
Vielen dank und wenig meint für den themenvorschlag, ich erinnere mich noch
wie steve jobs die pläne für das neue apple hauptquartier den lokalen politikerinnen und politikern vorgestellt hat und was für ein
Unglaubliches gebäude da dann entstanden ist genau so ist es jetzt auch in los angeles passiert nicht ihnen macht selbst
Aber seine verantwortlichen manager haben großes vor und jetzt die genehmigung dafür von lokalen politik bekommen
Es wird eine riesige fabrik und das im hafen von los angeles denn mit dem bau
Der bfa werden vollkommen neue dimensionen
der raumfahrt erreicht und da stoßen die
Entwicklungsteams an ihre grenzen und zwar an transport grenzen, die neue riesige rakete wird nämlich voraussichtlich
Die größe her, bis größte bisher überhaupt hergestellte rakete und das hat konsequenzen
Sie kann nämlich nicht mehr irgendwo produziert werden eine solch riesiger rakete und auch nur teile von ihr können nicht mehr über land transportiert
werden straßen sind dafür einfach zu schmal und zu klein, es gibt nur eine möglichkeit um die raketenteile auszuliefern und
Gelandete stufen wieder in die fabrik zurück zu transportieren
Die fabrik muss sich in einem hafen befinden
Deshalb hat spacex jetzt einen ziemlich großen teil des hafens von los angeles gepachtet für 0 dollar
20 jahre muss das unternehmen nichts bezahlen
Dafür baut es auf dem gelände eine riesige halle in der die
Raketen montiert werden sollen schon bis zum ende des jahres soll die fabrik fertig sein
Denn noch dieses jahr sollen die ersten versuche mit der bfh staaten laut, was soll die letzte stufe, also die spitze
Der rakete mit hopper flüge getestet werden dabei wird
Das schiff mehrere kilometer in die atmosphäre geschossen und wieder gelernt
Maskat, bisher keine zeitpläne mehr für mögliche mission zum mars bekannt gegeben, da ist inzwischen vorsichtig geworden
Aber die ersten tests in erd orbit sollen in drei bis vier jahren beginnen, also eine mars-mission schon 2022
Jetzt schon mal angekündigt hatte ist so nicht mehr machbar
Das ist auch kein wunder denn die bfh ist wirklich eine ganz neue herausforderung werden, die völker 9 noch
22 8 tonnen in die niedrige erdumlaufbahn bringen, konnte waren es bei der falcon heavy mit
63,8 tonnen schon drei mal so viel, aber die big fate locken soll bis zu
250 tonnen in eine niedrige umlaufbahn bringen
Zehnmal so viel wie die felgen ein der absolute wandeln, es wird also spannend, wie schnell jetzt alles geht mit der neuen fabrik sind
Jedenfalls die besten voraussetzungen geschaffen
ja
Und jetzt muss ich mal eine lanze für maniac brechen sein kann als flips mit allem über filme serien und genc die macht dann zusammen
Mit bad und die kennen sich wirklich unglaublich gut aus, also nicht das abo mit der
von flitz vergessen
Also mit der glocke dafür hier draufklicken meine absolute empfehlung und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken live erster staat
Der welt in heavy, das ist wirklich absolute gänsehaut, wie das da abgelaufen ist, ansonsten bis dann
Bleibt dran?